au lendemain du premier tour la guyane
retient aussi toutes les attentions avec
un des seuls ministres candidats arrivés
en tête léon bertrand la liste ump du
secrétaire d'état au tourisme a
recueilli 24 % une avancée fragile
exposés à un jeu d'alliances compliquées
entre trois listes de gauche désunie
jusqu'à maintenant dont celles de
l'ancienne candidate aux présidentielles
christiane taubira trois ou quatre
listes sont donc possible dimanche
prochain tout reste ouvert jusqu'à ce
soir est dans la rue personne n'ose de
pronostic
[Musique]
les alliances
ça va faire mal
il faut changer il faut essayer autre
chose voir s'il n'y a pas mieux que de
rester toujours de la même situation
il faut essayer d'avoir une chance pour
gagner les quatre lignes
même s'ils vont tous ce soir je pense
qu'ils ont une chance de gagner c'est un
peu mitigé parce qu'on sait pas qui va
être tout et après ça va ça va se
discuter au niveau de la présidence de
la région c'est moi il va falloir qu'il
ya des alliances pour que
certains qui sont en place puisse rester
mais sinon ça va basculer à doigts
attendant les alliances
attendons qu'ils valaient avec qui
vera